Wow - так називається цей сорт голландської троянди,
яка в Україні під час Помаранчевої революції
набула популярності через свій колір.
Тоді дуже добре продавався, на ура.
Голландська "Вау" успішно прижилася в теплицях під Бердичевом.
А разом з нею ще 15 сортів троянд.
Тут щорічно вирощують майже 6 млн. квіток.
Клімат, в принципі, такий, як на Еквадорі,
тому що температура вночі 16 градусів,
22-24 градуси вдень.
У 2015 році підприємці переорієнтували
свій бізнес з вирощування огірків та помідорів
на більш перспективні троянди.
Аби створити такий трояндовий "Еквадор", бізнесменам  довелося
докласти багато зусиль для пошуку грошей.
Не завжди ми можемо отримати кредити
в українських банках, тому що там
або дуже висока відсоткова ставка, або дуже тривалий процес
оформлення, який за часом не збігається
з нашими потребами,  бо це ж рослини.
2 мільйони гривень товариство отримало
завдяки спільній німецько-українській кредитній програмі,
яка діє вже кілька років і підтримує,
зокрема, бізнесу сільській місцевості.
Цього року німецький уряд вирішив відкрити
ще одну кредитну лінію для підтримки малого та середнього
бізнесу на 10 мільйонів євро.
Важливо, що німецькі кредити вперше будуть гривневими.
Ми підписали угоду з Євросоюзом.
І ЄС бере на себе валютні ризики, які виникають
під час конвертації євро в гривню.
Німецькі гроші розподілять на шість українських банків.
Кредити видаватимуться не менше, ніж на рік.
Прийом заявок від малого та середнього бізнесу вже розпочався.
Ті, які створюють робочі місця,
це не торгівля, а, наприклад, переробна промисловість,
взуття, пошив взуття, легка промисловість.
Максимальний розмір кредиту
це 250000 євро в перерахунку на гривню
Ідея така, щоб дати відсоток 17%
тому, хто бере кредит.
Така відсоткова ставка діятиме в Києві,
в інших регіонах вона може бути дещо вищою -19%.
Утім, це значно полегшує життя бізнесу,
вважають в теплицях під Бердичевом.
Адже нині підприємці платять щонайменше 22% річних.
Також поява на фінансовому ринку
трьохсот мільйонів гривень від Німеччини
може стимулювати українські банки пом’якшити умови кредитування.